[Music]
hi my name is Lisa Raye and I'm on the
developer relations team at Google today
I'm going to be talking about the
storage access framework in KitKat
specifically the client apps ID in our
last episode about the storage access
framework we saw the new system
documents UI that lets a user of your
app browse content from all apps on the
device that share documents today we're
going to walk through how to launch the
UI and how to handle the results in your
app there's more to it than there used
to be new and Android KitKat our
document editing writing and saving in
place and document creation and deletion
here's a quick picture of the flow as
you can see document providers and
clients don't interact directly just as
before a client requests permission to
interact with files read edit create etc
the system picker goes to each
registered provider and shows the user
the matching content finally the user
selects a document and the system grants
the client app permissions just for that
URI let's talk about action open
document this isn't much different than
what you may have done before you're
going to create an intent category open
amol means we only want results that can
be open basically documents as opposed
to a list of contacts or time zones the
type is the document mime type you want
here I'm asking for any type of image
and then launch your intent with a
request code this can be any value you
like but it should be unique within your
app and we've launched the file picker
next the user selects the document and
it's back to your app retrieving a URI
is also the same as before we get a
callback and on activity result we check
the request code matches and the result
came back ok now we don't get back the
specific document directly here we get a
URI pointing to it using intent get data
if you've done this before with the get
content or pick intents nothing's
changed and this might look familiar to
with a URI we can get metadata about the
image here this query applies to only
one document and we want all the rows
that's what all those nulls are for here
I'm getting its display name note this
is not the same as its file name and
size you can't count on getting a
reliable size for a document because it
might be stored remotely for example so
always check that it isn't Noah before
you try and get the size but forget
metadata you probably want to open this
image
here's a shortcut you can use content
resolver open file descriptor you pass
in the URI and the access mode you want
and you get back a parcel file
descriptor which is a wrapper around a
file descriptor for images there's a
handy method in bitmap factory decode
file descriptor don't do this on the UI
thread do it in the background use an
async task there's an example of this in
the storage client sample code that
we're posting and finally it's best
practice to wrap the clothes in a try
finally block so it's guaranteed to
close and then you can set this image to
an image view and here it is now wait
you're saying I want to do something
else or I don't have an image easy you
can get an input stream from the content
resolver and do whatever you want with
it
here I'm reading the lines of my file
into a string
so here's a new one we weren't able to
do this before you can get an output
stream from the content resolver
by default it uses write mode you want
to ask for the least amount of access
you need so don't ask for read/write if
all you need is right when I'm done I
just let the document provider know I'm
done by closing the stream which you
have to do anyway simple so we could
open one document before
what about lots of documents at the same
time all you have to do is to let the
user select multiples is add extra allow
multiple it's your intent if you want
you can specify multiple mime types this
time we get back clip data it's in
stored an intent get clip data and you
can get the you are eyes using clip data
get items and then item get URI note
that you still have to check intent get
data the same as a single URI because if
the user picks just one document doesn't
matter if you allowed multiple selection
it's still coming back the first way in
intent get data so you have to check
both creating a document is also new an
Android KitKat and it's really
straightforward
you give your intent a mime type a file
name and you launch it with a unique
request code the rest is taken care of
for you you get back its URI in on
activity result and that way you can
continue to write to it or whatever else
you want and deleting a document is even
easier you can't launch an intent to
delete a document but if you have its
URI which you would if you've opened or
created it then you can ask to delete it
and documents contract does this for you
again in a documents metadata you can
check document column flags if that
contains support delete you'll know
whether to enable or disable your delete
button or menu option one more thing to
mention when you open a file for reading
or writing the system gives you a URI
permission grant for that file it lost
until your device restarts however you
might want to access that file again
directly from your application say
you're an image editing app and you want
to show the user the last five images
they've edited if the device is turned
off in the meantime you won't have
access to those you could send the user
back to the document picker
but that's far from ideal instead you
can per miss persist the permissions the
system gave you
now they'll last no matter whether the
phone is turned off and on the system
won't do this automatically for you your
app has to explicitly request that the
permissions be persistent this is a
security measure that's a good thing one
last note you may have saved the most
recent URIs your app accessed but you
should still always use content resolver
get persisted URI permissions to check
that you have the freshest data other
applications could delete documents apps
could be removed so make this check to
make sure your data is right that's all
for now hope you enjoyed learning about
the new storage access features in
Android KitKat thanks for watching and
happy document sharing
you